je crois profondément que notre
stratégie était compte tenu des
informations qui étaient les nôtres la
bonne s'il ya une deuxième vague qui
arrive est ce que cette fois ci nous
serons prêts oui nous serons prêts
rien ne dit que nous aurons une seconde
vague rien ne dit que nous n'aurons pas
de seconde vague
je dis aux français organisez vos
déplacements organiser vos vacances
la france est prête à empêcher une
seconde vague
[Musique]
grâce à eux
grâce à la mobilisation de tous nous
avons renforcé nos moyens pour faire
face
aucune de ces mesures ne sera suffisante
si nous faisons le soin du statu quo
[Musique]
deuxième vague était possible voire
probable et nous l'avions anticipé
regarder autour de nous aucun pays
n'avait prévu qu'elle s'accélère ray de
manière à la fois aussi soudaine est
aussi brutale
[Musique]
le risque d'une deuxième vague une vraie
deuxième bas d'une réapparition fin
octobre ou en novembre ou en décembre et
un risque qui doit être considérée
[Musique]